all right so if you're an n a valorem
fan you know what we've got for you
today
before their match against immortals in
n a masters
a hundred thieves refused to start the
game because they were arguing with the
tournament organizer about what server
to play on
and now a video of some of that argument
has been published
online 100 thieves coach has been put on
probation for a full
year and the team has been fined five
grand
here's how it all went down
[Music]
all right guys so if you love valerie if
you want to see the score do more valor
in content just like i do
make sure you scroll down subscribe to
the channel and turn on notifications
so you never miss a video all right so
as i'm sure many of you already know
valerian masters one was a pretty
[ __ ] long
tournament this event spanned two weeks
and
ended with tens and sentinels becoming
the first ever major tournament winners
in north america but that
is not what this story is about for this
story
i've gotta take you back to march 12th
when a hundred thieves played immortals
in the upper bracket quarterfinals now
if you're like me
and you were anxiously awaiting hiko and
company's
first game in masters you were
pretty caught off guard when the match
was delayed by like
a full hour and of course we now know
why it was delayed
because a hundred thieves and their
coach frost did not agree with the
methodology the tournament organizer
nerdstreetgamers
was using to decide what server the
games would be played on
here's hiko explaining how the whole
situation went down
the day after the match nerd street was
not being consistent
in their rulings when it came to server
selection
they made a ruling last week when we
played tsm that
differed from the ruling they made this
week against immortals
so we were arguing with them for a bit
to the point where
we had to get ride involved for riot to
make an official ruling because
it wasn't handled very well
with nerd street so that's why it took
so long
as you heard from the sova stand himself
their main point of contention was that
nerd street had allegedly changed the
way that they decided on servers from
one week to the next
and for all of you that don't know why
the any of this server stuff matters
let me explain quick competitive online
games have servers in different parts of
the world
that the game pings to connect to the
larger the difference between where you
are and where the server is
will give you a higher number of
milliseconds it takes for your game
to ping the server a higher number of
milliseconds
or a higher ping generally means a
disadvantage
this is particularly true in fps games
and even more true in a game like
valorant where peaker's advantage exists
long story short as an example if a
hundred thieves had three guys with 50
ping
and two guys with five and immortals had
five guys
with five ping a hundred thieves would
be pretty mad
now flash forward from when this all
happened to yesterday
march 23rd riot games released this
competitive ruling
regarding the incident a dispute over
player ping
delayed the start of the upper bracket
quarterfinals match between 100 thieves
and
immortals by one hour a hundred thieves
prevented the start of the series
despite the explicit instructions
of the tournament operator to begin the
series furthermore 100 thieves head
coach
hector frost rosario demonstrated
unprofessional behavior towards a
tournament official we are finding a
hundred thieves five thousand dollars
for an extensive broadcast delay due to
non-compliance with tournament
official decisions and are placing frost
on competitive probation
for the duration of the 2021 valorant
champions tour
yeah so basically they decided to find a
hundred thieves five grand for delaying
the tournament
which is not a lot at all for an esports
organization they also chose to place a
hundred thieves coach
frost on probation for the entirety of
the 2021
champions tour that's a full year
and that my fellow valor and fans is
where [ __ ] hit the fan in response to
riot's statement
hundred thieves released a statement of
their own challenging the ruling
and denying the fact that frost ever
used the player's social media presence
to gain leverage in the argument which
is something riot stated in their
statement
they also clarified that they felt that
the ruling the tournament organizers
made
in regards to the servers was in quote
direct
contradiction to one they made the week
prior against team solomid
which is what started all of this
notably they also said that they planned
to pay their fine and move on
which didn't really happen because
immediately after
they released four minutes of actual
video footage of the argument frost had
with the tournament organizers
from his side but it has to apply in the
exact same way joseph you can't just
arbitrarily change the rules and if
you're going to do that
we can fight back by just literally not
playing and if you dc against us
or if you give us a dc you're in a
bigger [ __ ] storm than we are
there is a huge difference with eight
ping compared to 44 by the way
on every game it's worse than this game
than it is let's say rocket league so if
your argument is that then sure
i mean we can argue semantics there but
not in the shooting game the people's
advantage
is a thing and riot has also said it's a
thing and they are aware that it's a
thing and they publicly have stated this
the first thing that you came in here to
say is shut up
gunba yo i don't know who the [ __ ] you
think you are but you need to relax
first off i didn't i haven't said
anything
i haven't said anything to you i'm not
even talking to you as a matter of fact
you shouldn't even be here
packing and i should be here you need to
get out of here and you definitely don't
need to start telling somebody
shut up when me and josie are having a
discussion
now after watching this it's first
important to say a couple things
first this is only one side of the
conversation
we can't hear what the tournament
organizers have to say two
this is only four minutes of a
conversation that very easily could have
been a lot longer
with that said it did appear to get
heated and frost
absolutely did say the words quote if
you dcs
you're going to be in a bigger [ __ ]
storm than we are which 100 thieves said
in their statement was the extent to
which
any of the player's social media
presence was being leveraged
and as you might imagine this video sent
esports twitter into a
tailspin because there are a lot of
disputes in esports
but let me tell you as someone who does
this for a living it's not every day
that there's
actual video footage of the conversation
and this story doesn't end with just
one four minute video in direct response
to the video that 100 thieves posted
riot games issued yet another statement
on tuesday night
in their second statement they added a
key amendment
and said that three independent
witnesses confirmed that
frost threatened to use the player's
social media presence
outside of that one statement 100
thieves included against the tournament
organizers
quote three independent witnesses
provided testimony that frost made a
statement to this effect
when asked directly about it in an
interview by riot league operations
personnel
frost admitted that he had made this
statement although hundred thieves
provided riot with a clip showing
frost's side of the conversation
that does not include the statement they
declined to provide the full video to
riot
end quote and that my friends is all we
know so far so what we have here
is riot games releasing an original
ruling 100 thieves then contesting that
ruling saying that frost
never used the player's social media
clout to win
an argument over server ping then 100
thieves releases a four minute video of
the argument
and then riot games says yeah but that's
not the whole thing
he did do that and we have three
witnesses telling us
that he did do that now according to
riot's ruling any
further non-compliance with the rules
over the course of the 2021 valorem
champions tour
could lead to further penalties or even
bans for frost
as for nerd street gamers well they only
tweeted one
thing on the night of march 23rd and it
was a particularly
topical and funny video now as for the
actual ruling
who's at fault and who took things too
far well
it's hard to say if you watch that video
it's extremely clear that frost was
unhappy with whatever was going on
and he was not afraid to tell who was
ever on the other end of that line
how unhappy he was on the other hand if
decisions really were being made
unfairly
maybe he has a point i mean this is
online esports
ping matters either way given this is
the first quote unquote
act of defiance against riot in valorant
they acted swiftly what do you think do
you think ryan was too harsh on 100
thieves or were 100 thieves out of line
let me know in the comments what i'll
say about that devin is that
considering you have this well-known
gaming syndrome called run in and die
alone
i would certainly consider your ping
because peeker's advantage
matters a lot for someone who ego peaks
every corner
question mark question mark